what's up guys my name is Evan Kidd I'm
a filmmaker from North Carolina and
actually recently just created my debut
feature film son of clowns
it is a 95 minute feature we shot
completely independently and it was
filmed with the Canon c100 you know if
filmmaking is a whole I think a lot of
times we get roped into what camera is
the best or you know what specs can work
best for this film every year there's a
brand new camera and I think for me I
really break a camera down or a choice
of camera for any film I make based on
what's going to really push us to the
furthest capabilities of what we can do
to get me the most time with my actors
you know I'm a director first and
foremost but I also do DP work as well
for other people's films so it kind of
puts me in an interesting position to
where you know I do a lot of corporate
DP work I do narrative DP work I just
shot a short in New Orleans this past
week and it's really interesting because
I actually use the 64 that but you know
for what we were trying to go for the
director told me we need to move fast we
have to make our days it's imperative
the location we're in you know we got to
be in and out so for me it was
interesting just because I needed the
camera that would really make me as
nimble and quick as possible while also
kind of minimizing the setups you need
to do you know something that could be
handheld if it needed to be so I think a
lot of those decisions are very vital
and key and you know coming back to my
film son of clowns my director of
photography Ned Phillips actually owned
the Canon c100 and I really do think the
Canon c100 is probably one of the best
filmmaking tools in terms of camera that
you can get today as an independent
filmmaker we thought about renting we
thought about using my own personal 5d
but kind of came back to what's going to
give us the highest quality image
because it was a feature and we wanted
to really push it a little past the
territory of a DSLR if we could you know
by no means where we against it but you
know at the same time we thought about
the C 100 and C 300 line and it made the
most sense because Ned our DP owned that
C 100 he also owned it at most ninja
recorder and it's great because it's
actually a monitor that you can put on
top of your C 100 rig and what that
allows you to do is not only view your
image obviously bigger as opposed to
looking on the viewfinder or the LCD
screen built into the camera but really
it also lets you record flat a very flat
image which is almost raw it doesn't
record true raw does record Apple Pro
res but for our intents and purposes
that was perfect because I'm one of
those who really liked to get in there
and the editor when it comes down to it
and really great every fine detail I
love color correction I love getting in
there and really for us it made the most
sense because on a budget the camera
that allowed us to move the quickest and
to do the least number of setups and to
be on the go was the c100 and to me that
was just an added treat you know we
originally were not expecting to have
that ninja so it really allowed us to
push the image further what you're
seeing right now on the screen is a flat
image directly from the ninja camera on
Sun of clowns again this is raw image
and now you're seeing the color graded
image and you can see the intricacies
and kind of how far you could really
push it you know to me honestly the flat
image looks pretty great on its own a
lot better than the digital version
which we also would record as a backup
so basically the way we had our rig was
Ned would record directly into the ninja
but we'd have a backup of everything we
did on the SD card from the c100 and
that was not a bad look at all
but we really enjoyed having that flat
image at our disposal later down the
road in the Edit I'm really inspired by
resource based filmmaking absolutely
consider myself an independent filmmaker
really on every level and so for me when
we came to looking for a camera it was
all about accessibility and portability
I love the handheld look so the c100 is
great because you know it's not huge but
it's also big enough to where if you
were to handhold it if you have an
awesome DP like I did in ED you can
basically have a very good handheld
image that's also pretty stable you know
you really have some good weight on that
c100 between everything on it especially
if you're throwing that ninja adapter
like we had so it's a great camera for
handheld you know you don't really have
to build a whole bunch of shoulder rigs
and steady cams and mounts because in my
opinion if your DP is skilled enough you
will be okay and you'll get that
handheld image that's not like super
crazy
or anything like that because again
looking at the images that we captured
we were on the move so much and you know
for us it was really a matter of you
know 14 plus hour days I think our
longest day was close to 20 hours it was
just absolutely nuts
we shot son of clowns on a production
schedule of ten shooting days so the
camera had to adapt the camera had to be
just as game as all of our crew members
you know our crew members were basically
doing the indie film thing where you
know sleeping on air mattresses really
accessible locations trying to cram a
lot of pages into a day while still you
know taking the time we needed you know
for me my number one priority is really
how can I get as much time devoted to my
actors as possible and so I knew in the
c100 that it would be a great versatile
camera because we wouldn't have that
many tech issues we wouldn't have to
have much freezing or anything like you
might get in a red or something more you
know quote-unquote fancy you do want
something that won't give you a lot of
crap along the way you know filmmaking
as they say is hard enough as it is so
why complicate yourself or complicate
your matters as a filmmaker for me again
that c100 really truly resonated well
and again it gelled with the type of
flow we were going for as a film and I
think that flow is great because if you
have a camera that's fighting the flow
of your film you know if you're you know
somehow getting your hands on you know a
really fancy camera that takes a lot of
time a lot of setup you know you can't
just run a gun with it then you are
going to have to build your days as a
film and as a production to accommodate
that because again I don't want to get
bogged down if my production schedule is
only ten days and we can't go over so it
was imperative we made our days it was
also imperative that our camera match
that mentality so just a note for people
out there if you are looking for a 4k
camera that is a drawback c100 does not
have that I truly at this point don't
really care too much for 4k I think down
the road I will but you know again as a
resource based independent filmmaker I
know my means I know my level so for me
4k wasn't really even on the table so
you know if you are looking for that you
might want to look elsewhere but for me
the 1080p that we did man
to capture from the image on the c100
with the ninja Apple ProRes again very
close to raw so seeing that ProRes
resolution at four to two was just
imperative ly great in my opinion gave
me what I wanted for an independent
feature and really pushed the boundaries
to what we thought that c100 could even
do in the first place our big boy lens
which we actually shot probably 90% of
the film on was the Canon 24 to 105 L
Series lens in my opinion a great piece
of glass all around very versatile you
know if I had my choice I'd love to have
you know fixed prime lenses for every
single shot but I knew that the way we
were gonna shoot would not dictate that
we needed to be able to zoom I needed
Ned to have the range he needed quickly
and for him not to be bogged down by
switching lenses with me every 10
seconds if I wanted a different angle
you know one set up or one shot later so
that 24 to 105 with the zoom really gave
us a crisp and clear image while being
you know high enough piece of glass to
differentiate it from other zoom once's
while still giving us the range and the
flexibility to move fast and keep that
production schedule on point budget was
tight production days were slim so we
really had to make do with what we had
and I think the fact that we had such a
great cast and crew that really gelled
and really accommodated one another you
know from our camera department down to
our actors to everyone else on Sun of
clowns so really when it came down to it
we would pool our resources together and
really make the best film that we could
make and I think community and resource
based filmmaking like that where you
know maybe you don't have enough money
to get read but you know you have the
lens and your buddy who shoots stuff has
the body of the camera you come together
you make a nice little camera package
and that's basically what we did and I
think if you find dedicated hard-working
passion individuals who are you know
willing to do that with your film with
your camera or what-have-you you'll
really create the best film that you can
and create a great image